so we dad is a name of this talk is the
opposite of big data and so I want to
talk about how can be really
useful and for applications of any size
no matter how small the data set that
you're working with is and that's
basically because offers
applications the ability to persist data
I mean and then offline rather not
inside the scope of the application that
you're building query that data and at
the same time doesn't require you to
sort of switch languages you know mid
code right embedding sequel into their
code is really terrible way to go and
there are other solutions who's using
ORM in an application show hands do you
guys love RM you guys put up with the RM
right ok so a little bit about me so
maybe I should stand away from the
see if I can thanks for here okay so
this is me I am a technology innovator I
like to sprinkle technology pixie dust
everywhere I go so the way I put it and
I started my career is software engineer
i work two double click for a while I go
to shopwiki shopping search engine that
i'll refer to later and became event
after five years opposed from a CTO that
outfit and then for the past couple of
years I've been sort of freelance and
this is this is what I offer expertise
at the intersection of Technology this
isn't a strategy and formulation I don't
always get the order right when I say it
is it's an intersection and the stuff
that I'm into involves products /
technology I don't love you know pure
technology ventures although
technologies awesome I'm really into
things that delight people you know
where technology is applied it makes
people lives better I like user
experience testing I like being able to
watch people interact with applications
and have an aha moment they
able to in figure out this this use case
will have to defeat you know I'll have
to figure out a better way of making an
evident to them what they're supposed to
do I like to work with iterative
analytics driven development this was
something that I learned its Apogee and
wells a lot of observing whether users
are being satisfied by the thing that
you're offering I'm just reiterating
slowly on that and agility everyone
knows about agile development by now
when I was first when i was first
graduating from CS program extreme
programming have just had some books
written about it but everyone goes agile
now right everybody yeah right are you
how many people have worked on a project
that they think is agile maybe how many
people have not okay yeah right okay so
agile is I mean as was a thing now and
that actually is one of the motivators
for projects like using in
your you know in your project because it
suits an ad little development workflow
better than other sorts of data
persistence layers particularly now that
agility is starting to be measured not
in how quickly your release cycle you
know how compressed air release cycle is
how how quickly can respond to changing
business needs but actually being
actually having your production
environment respond to events spinning
up new instances you know doing seema
migrations I live in line I'll talk a
little more
later is supports that their
notice I haven't really haven't really
talked a lot about big dated at all
because this the advantages of having a
schema free data layer is you know comes
to you whether or not you have a
terabyte or a megabyte of data because
you still have to write the same amount
of code to manage the processes we need
to when you need to go from one sort of
burden of your day is similar to another
okay sue so this shop looking this was
my first exposure to MongoDB this is
where I first now shopwiki is a is a
shopping search engine now when we were
founded well I wasn't on board when it
was founded but but I came on a year
later but when you know what what we
thought was you know kind of you know
shopping comparison has not been really
treated properly yet and we're going to
do it differently we're going to be a
destination site people are going to
know our names and when someone wants to
buy digital camera
going to thank to themselves we go to
shopping search for digital camera
created five megapixels under two
hundred dollars and just going to come
off and I'm going to choose the store
consolidate all the stores that have
camera is based on there and you know
that's not the way it turned out turns
out shopping key which is which still
exists and is profitable I left a two
years ago is essentially an SEO game and
it's all about getting between a google
search and someone buying something and
taking a share of that revenue now in
order to go from a start-up with very
little revenue to making money on this
these refs shares purely but with I mean
that we aren't you know if you don't
have money to invest in some sort of
advertising drive traffic to your site
you have to get it the natural light
Google and so our a choppa get our
consumer was the Google search engine so
we need to figure out you SEO now since
step shopwiki is a search driven site
the pages are infinite there's no
content per se and so you there's no
analytics solution that would help us
actually that would help us actually
gather all the data and partition the
pages into the a be testing AP testing
anybody everybody okay good absolutely
so um so and romano mambo is actually a
fantastic place to put your roll your
own you know custom analytics logging
data because every time you decide you
need to add some new field to study oh
and now we're going to measure how many
seconds it took before someone who's on
your page oh now we're going to count
the number you know whatever the
different things that you want to count
in your analytics you just you just
throw it into your document that logs a
page view and you don't have to worry
about my grading schemas right doing all
these you know these migrations taking
out scheduling down time dealing with
dealing with redundancy and all that
sort of thing so it was here that I used
for the very first time is not a
coincidence actually it's not like I
just happened on it's because shah
pahlavi was also founded by these guys
so I went to school with this guy and I
did soccer projects together so um you
know so when dwight and elliot got you
know tired of doing shopping comparison
because they had already done the whole
data crawling thing and went on to do
10gen bit of history everyone knows that
was part of a much bigger platform
yeah so is just sort of
the data persistence layer a much more
ambitious project but they started I've
done when they went on to when they want
to do tengen they just moved to guess
rows behind where all the shop with you
guys are in the same office and so we
started to use and a lot of places
possibly possibly in appropriate places
as well but we learned a lot about
during them so so that was my first use
of now the inspiration for this
fog came out of a very different project
a couple of I think it is about a year
ago megan gale who's organizing
community asked me if I had to talk to
you and I had already been out of shop
okie for a little while I I haven't
worked with a big amount of installation
forever but I did actually use mom go
for this project so this is a website
that my parents started without having
any idea what they were getting into
they knew not the first thing about
e-commerce and like her ten months after
the project started and I hooked them up
with a an agency to do design and
development of this e-commerce site they
were foundering they they they were
certainly they knew their name you there
yield so judaica I'll just give it a
very quick description of what this is
for those who don't know what judaica is
hands up actually most people
yes but Judea God is sort of a sort of a
cross between artistic and original
objects for Jews to use like blessing
cups of wine on the Saturday ok so the
what my parents looked around with and
saw was that basically everyone is
selling judaica online in crappy mall
like low and looking sites and they
thought well you know we know artists we
like to go to shows we can we have good
relationships will simple to do a
boutique II sort of thing great idea
like I said 10 months on and the site is
nowhere to be found and they can't even
communicate properly so you know to the
rescue and off I go to you know to take
over the entire project and get launched
and it's up now that's good and it was
it was in this context that I found that
I was going to use long go again so but
I didn't need it for any of the back end
I mean there was you know go into this a
little more but first I want to segue
into a book them the nature of big data
because that's what everyone talks about
these days this is it is the big you
know it's a big deal big big data is not
just all over the tech rags they'll find
it in technology articles in mainstream
media and it is true that big data is
going to change the world as we know so
who thinks that they're working on big
data right now what are you guys working
on call them out sure
okay how is big data part of your like
what qualifies your application is a big
data so what's side what sort of size of
data set are we talking about terabytes
okay so easily terabytes that's I think
where the where the where the big data
threshold starts you did nothing we have
to have multiple terabytes is everyone
agree with that right I would stipulate
furthermore that you can't you know you
don't just need a lot of data to be a
big data problem you need to have a lot
of data that you actively touch every
single time you do not ratio is you know
data warehousing is old right big data
is about I don't like sequencing the
human genome what else who else is doing
big data what you got
so this is uh this is to my point
exactly anyone else will talk about
their big data project in the back
can you yell out the name of the project
again crisp GRI tryst and can you do you
have off hand some data set sizes to
quote
ok
mm-hmm right
okay so so this is so that's a lot of
data but that's not really what people
are talking about i think when they say
big data big data the change the world
kind of big data is was really was
really introduced when people found that
they could realistically address
terabytes of data per operation now this
does not come cheaply odds are a very
small percentage of you will work on
really true the big data problems in the
next few use they are out there but I
think it's worth understanding that
there is a ratio of Big Data projects to
the total projects out there and I'm
going to say that that's the ratio just
putting it out there disagreement
hmm
right exactly that's a very good
question no this is just I mean this is
I'm just pulling it out but I mean I i
have yet to i have yet to talk to
someone who's who is working off I mean
not yet to obviously I think I think I
think a lot of the new advertising
platforms and obviously all the so
people that are working social media
look like all of the social media data
at once are working on Big Data project
but the fact is you know you do yeah me
if you work on code you work on tiny
projects all the time you're always
prototyping something new right and
there are some projects that are just
never going to use a lot of data and so
I started to think especially because
Megan asked me to talk about and
the only project that I had at hand to
talk about was a little etl thing that I
did for the Petrov's project this new
concept that we did you are we dad
somehow I hear it scotch but I can't do
the accent
but it's between and it's never supposed
to get bigger sometimes you sound like a
like you have a project where you have
where you hope that it will grow to be
massive but you know you the scale is
not enormous now that's one version of
this of this problem space where you
know maybe you're going to grow to be
huge but right now you're not and
another another areas common spaces the
truly small data set size query
performance is not an issue in this case
right I mean and I mean in fact your
whole database might fit in right on
your laptop or on your phone it's uh you
know this is it just because your
application does not process a lot of
data doesn't mean that you're going to
write less code to manipulate it if you
need to you need to do if you need to do
something useful with it and it doesn't
mean that you're not going to benefit
from having a super slick data
persistence and interrogation layer that
offers features over and over beyond a
key value store and that uses semantics
that mimics the type of semantics that
you're used to using when you code on
objects right documents are objects but
you don't need to use all toolkit just
to persist them to documents
alright so I'm saying is the
solution for this sort of problem space
so it scales down nicely and by which I
mean to say that there is not a lot to
do to start working with Mara as a layer
in your application if you know brew
install whatever like your
whatever your management system for
choices get it going the driver for
whatever application you're using and
now you're just writing to collections
that you don't really have to start to
drive out a whole object hierarchy I
mean you still write procedural code if
you like sometimes we do you don't have
to have like a whole you know object
persisting rules set so you can access
it you can access it programmatically
without using something like SQL there's
a whole generation above developers who
have learned SQL as part of their
education either a formal education like
I received where where databases were
part of the computer science curriculum
and you're going to learn SQL because
anytime you need to write an application
that's going to have a day of
persistence layer your custom rolling
which you want to not do you're going to
use SQL but that's just because that was
then this is now right there's there is
not necessarily a need for us to mingle
SQL and two are no indoor code in order
to think about decomposing your objects
or or whatever you're using for your day
representation in to tabulate relational
data so persistence that's nice you can
always look at your data later after you
work after you work with it and uh and
that way and so you can still a girl ok
so I've alluded to this before but there
exists this thing alarm which has been
this has been a thing for I think 20
years now there there VIN ORM liars 71
heard of web objects that was the first
time I encountered an ORM layer when
objects I don't think it exists anymore
of an apple was Apple I think that this
is true team from next because they it
was the first one of the first
application development frameworks for
the web and it was first in Objective C
which is now big again because people do
my OS development and then they quarter
to java and that's when I met but
obviously the for those rubyists out
there at the record is the is the name
of the note and I mean it's a solution
right if you have to persist your data
and the only thing you can persist it to
is an SQL so a relational database great
you have you have active record and not
going to trash talk active record it's
pretty cool I'm down with that calm who
loves active record out here anyone
cricket good it is good I mean it's
there I think they're there they're big
thing is and it goes along with the
whole rails methodology is convention
over configuration I think is the idea
um I haven't worked with it on enough
projects extensively enough to sort of
rattle off examples of how it is nifty
but it is one of the better options if
you want to have an RN layer um it is
not a solution to it by any means to the
problem of needing to kick start your
project and have some no data schema
that you've been you know effortlessly
maneuver around especially if you're
hoping to grow your project from me to
mid-sized right like Harding back to
that to my claim that these days agile
means agilent production let me just uh
relate a little anecdote about a year
and a half ago photobucket i think is
named the company did a talk for the
user group does anyone here
remember that talk they talk about their
migration from relational database to
and they did something that was
very clever all they did was they root
code that looked up users records in
and if it didn't find it there
they copied it over and then when they
had done that for like several months
they ran a batch script to sweep up all
the stragglers you know and you're done
that's a that's a live environment we
prefer doing this sort of thing to
scheduling downtime or partitioning your
application even worse so that you can
have one running while you do the
migration and then some sync up that
happens
afterwards disaster okay so you know our
I'm gets you my migrations that's a
thing does that the record as a single
migration for you where you actually
specify every time you update a schema a
way of translating of the former schema
to the to the new schema and it's got a
version so you can apply scheme spirit
it's very good it's a nice way to handle
the fact that you will have to update
schemas if you're working with our but
personally I think a better solution to
this is documents where the documents
are versioned if you care about the
schema right if you don't want to
interrogate the document to see if they
have an attribute that you care about
you can actually just version them and
you know fitting into this agile in
production motif I would rather have
library interrogate documents as they
come out of the database to find out
what they are you know whether they are
delinquent and require updating and
calling hooks to update them as that's
happening then actually migrate data on
this which is which is what you're going
to get if you work out with the with are
so in short I don't you know ORM ISM or
is no substitute for actually using a
layer that utilizes the right semantics
and matts more properly to your to just
native application development okay so
this brings me back to this project
right you guys heard of mom and pop
shops right this is literally my mom and
pop shop there's not an easy project to
work on
to tell you i have to tell you and it
was very clear from the very beginning
that that they would not be working with
the e-commerce back end they I couldn't
even trust them really to submit
spreadsheets with product data filled in
without them for some reason altering
the column headers you know sometimes
it's you know product name sometimes its
name sometimes it's you know merchant
Christ sometimes it's merchant costs
like yeah why just leave it alone still
data um so yeah but yeah mom and dad as
you want so you know there were certain
things that were already set by the time
I came to this like for example I wasn't
going to be the one to develop as
e-commerce chef I did hook them up with
a designer and a developer specialized
in some e-commerce self and me chose
magento which is written in PHP or go I
wasn't gonna be touching it and you know
I'm he and he had already begun work on
customizing it and he built a extension
to the bulk uploader that accepts CSV
documents so there was sort of a
workflow dictated already and it was
into this environment that I came Andrew
bunch of code to handle this now I'm
going to make a quick little segue to
talk about how i started to rewrite this
code using control slideshow we
behavior driven development so behavior
driven development is a super cool idea
that I cannot vouch for how well it
works and I was hoping that I would be
able to talk to some of you guys who
have actually worked on behavior here
development projects after the talk I
really like to hear from guys but I
encountered this concept during yet
another one of my forays into a ruby on
rails tutorial and and it was a very
very appealing concept behavior driven
development okay what is it so it's an
outside-in approach that's one of the
phrases they use frequently just to say
that you know again agile is not what it
used to be where you know there's there
was XP back in the day and there's like
strong and now con gone and all these
other things and there's sort of a
family of agile practices and test you
know behavior behavior driven
development is a layer on top of
test-driven development you know the
same way all of these new agile
processes are layered on top of the
original credos of test-driven
development okay so outside in from a
test driven development approach is we
write the code to test the code we're
gonna write before we write the code we
watch the test fail and then we make the
test pass by writing and we know we're
done when the tests are passing and this
is a and for this you get not you get
both specification for your code and
also regression tests everyone's
onboarding this right okay so behavior
driven development goes a layer out and
talks about acceptance tests or larger
features
unit testing for methods and objects and
then we have a behavior test for the
functionality of the program and it's
important to note that from this point
of view everything's behavior the fact
that an ATM can't machine dispenses some
money and debits and devon and
subtraction amount from your account
when you request money is behavior and
also the fact that some method takes two
arguments and returns a boolean is also
behavior it's all behavior okay so the
the next facet that I thought was really
interesting and and gets and begins to
illustrate the magic of this approach is
the notion of acceptance test driven
planning sessions where all of the
stakeholders in a project get together
the business analyst product owner
manager project manager QA engineers and
the software developers who are going to
be working on the product they all get
together during planning meetings is
this how you guys do it guess get you
know the guy to want features in the
same room as the developers are going to
be delivering them right when you guys
have meetings it works in Sprint's who
works in Sprint's not enough of you
so Sprint's begin with planning meetings
you have a backlog you know you take
care you take your you take the features
off the backlog agree that we're going
to work on these things for two weeks
then you work on them there's been there
has to be a meeting where you discuss
how the features are going to work and
in behavior driven development in that
meeting you are working on developing
what they refer to as a ubiquitous
language and this is an excitement I'll
bet that some of you have been
frustrated while working on projects
because among your teammates you're
using a certain set of vocabulary to
refer to to refer to the concepts that
drive your application and then you go
to a meeting and the sales people are
using completely different language and
so you know what happens when you the
one engineer on your team with social
skills gets sent off to odd quietly now
you put on your your best cargo shorts
and you know and you wind up with a
sales guy you guys are just talking crop
like the customers just not impressed
because you guys can't seem to use the
same words to talk about things it's
confusing and you know you're not all
oriented productively towards the same
direction and this miscommunication can
be a really rough day for any team
obviously to some extent it's just a
matter of culture but there are
definitely bugs that come out of you
know well we're talking about you know
depositing withdrawing but really it's
debiting and crediting all withdrawing
actually means that you do something
physical that indebted
something that happens to reg actually
don't work in finance out of this true
son I'm just making stuff but those are
the sorts of areas where like bugs can
prevent so the biggest language
acceptance that except just acceptance
test driven development with driven
planning where everyone gets together
uses their ubiquitous language to
specify the behavior or software before
we go ahead and even begin to write the
unit tests that are going to test the
code that we're going to write later and
in order to support this in the Ruby
world we use a tool called number wonder
if there's a way that I can make this a
little more visible I have blow ups so
cucumber is a is a language it's a with
a with a limited grammar that rings like
English where you specify the behavior
of software so here's the top of a
cucumber you're the first thing in
cucumber is uh is the feature you
describe it it's got a name here's part
of my Penrose project the CSV converter
handles xlsx files and the the
description over here is something
called connect straw format I think it
doesn't have to be in this format this
is freeform but it happens to be that in
this world and again I'm I'm not a guru
of this this was i used the Penrose
project as a learning opportunity to
pour over the r-spec on a cucumber book
and you know hung out on the IRC
channels and troll Google and everything
for this but you know basically this is
a means of organizing your thoughts
about about specifying features such
that you're always emphasizing roles and
value so in order to upload products to
the e-commerce site as a Penrose
administrator I want to convert xls
files to CSU and that is an advisable
way
to think about specifying the way
software behaves because you're always
concentrating and inverting as a Penrose
administrator you know you might want to
sort of flip it around depending on some
people and advocate other ways of
talking about this stuff but i think the
canonical example was if you're building
a travel site right and you want to
specify features for it how much
different is it when you say well as a
professional business traveler in order
to book a flight right you know your
features might be different than if you
are a occasional you know traveler who
doesn't travel for business all the time
so that's this is a you know an
important planning tool is thinking
about things in this way the rest of the
cucumber file is broken into some some
more rigid descriptions these are
actually part of the grammar for C
specify scenario here's a scenario valid
xlsx file given a valid XOX file with
the contents and here you see that one
of the features of cucumber is that it
allows you to specify tabular data
that's going to be passed into code that
actually executes when I invoke the CSV
converter on the file then it should
pass which is going 40 exit 0 exit
status with and then you know block of
course so these are so these are
conveniences for referring to the way
software behaves when you invoke it
here's a little tag so that when you run
your cucumber suite of features you get
you can sort of limit it to for this is
a work in progress tag so and then here
the step definitions separate file these
things are mapping regular expressions
that
match step definitions so this is a
given that a valid exilis file with the
contents and the table that was defined
over here is now bound to this variable
and I can play with it and I can assign
it to a to an instance variable that
this code executes in the context of an
object which will take this up and I can
set the test file name and create using
a little helper class the xls file with
the data that I specified in the table
and then you know here's another step
where I'm verifying that the CSV file
contains the same data as the xls file
contain and that's and that's specifying
features okay your inner layer in the
Ruby world is our spec there are lots of
spec libraries and may consist of the
following components for working on
software okay first specification how
you how methods should behave and then
in order okay actually I want to know
how many people are familiar with object
doubles methods dubbing expectations and
things of this nature okay some of you
guys now before I drag this on any more
I'd like to know how many people are
interested in hearing more about how you
can test code using these things all
right not enough I'm going to 12 put
them up if you really let's um let's
let's talk about this afterwards I'm
going to get on with it this is what our
stack looks like and you can find more
info over here I want to get to the sort
of did
the example here so here's the so here
is the example that inspired this whole
discussion of why is useful for
projects with a tiny data set size right
it's the Penrose etl pipeline extraction
extract translate envelope which is
essentially what we need to do with
spreadsheets to get them into an
e-commerce site now when I came on the
scene i mentioned that greg the
developer of the uploader the bulk
uploader had created something that was
going to read in csv files and that was
that that was how it was going to work
so okay good my parents could probably
save excel files as CSV but it's dicey
there are a couple of different CSV
formats a can necessarily rely on them
so we're going to work with products
spreadsheets but product any
descriptions and there's just no way
that they're going to type multi-line
descriptions into Excel cells I would
get a call literally every day asking
for a reminder how you insert a new line
into an Excel cell I'm not to mention
that's a shitty way to work I mean you
don't want to do that so there was going
to be blah blah blah physic rafts and
ship product description files formatted
separately okay so now the shape of the
problem is beginning to emerge we need
to get these product descriptions merged
with the specifications for the project
products built into a CSV file so that
it could be uploaded okay so can do this
in memory there's no reason why why I
couldn't do that but thinking things
through a little more I mean this is
going to be this is valuable data
metadata is available from this for all
kinds of business
Elliot's right so enter long gone right
we returned product spreadsheets into
intermediate CSV loaded into
documents for each product categories
arrays a you know a raise of attribute
categories comma separated in the in the
Excel spreadsheet turn into an array of
category names as an attribute of the
document database product descriptions
run a mapper finds the name those the
artist it links it up all in the
database and then I can export this
again to CSV and upload it to the
website but I can also do this and this
is just a little preview of the
aggregation operators that have been
introduced in 2.2 OS a anybody yeah look
it up later yeah I was reason it was
recent this did not exist when chapa he
was using that's which is why we
did a lot of like you know export to SQL
summary tables but should we buy ad
words for you know hanukkah's coming up
and and people want to buy menorahs well
should we buy the silver manoa keywords
well you can do that by running
aggregation on the data and finding out
how many there are if you have two of
them it's really not worth advertising
to drive traffic to your site for two
products but if you have lots of them
then good now this is only one example
that's
now this is the template for the wii
data project it is a project where you
have some data you going to mingle it
with a couple of sources now pre
you would do that in memory do whatever
you want and you just have to run that
every time so there's this as your data
may grow its going to get a little
slower you know but if it's really small
it doesn't matter but it doesn't have a
life beyond that mo q no federal moment
where you actually get your unit run
your query with with this sort of
structure you now have the ability to
interrogate this data for whatever you
want without having to constantly rerun
importance you can do dips you can you
can you can find out you can do how many
you know to the descriptions are too
short I want to rewrite all the
descriptions that are under like 50
characters and one more content beefing
up these things you name it sky's the
limit like the you know when once your
data is through mingled and persisted
you do whatever you want with it and
that is really the essence of the weed
data project so
go thank you questions anybody okay so
the question is the integration between
and ecommerce package there was no
direct integration the ecommerce package
runs on Oh actually I'm going to do this
live just so you guys can see the
difference of the two what happens
this
is the data schema oh whoops this is the
data schema for uh for magenta it's uh
look at this is ridiculous this is what
happens when you have to use aura for
your for your application don't do it
what's that don't use magenta that's
another thing but like I mean this is
inevitable this is absolutely inevitable
if you want to use a flexible extensible
thing that combines both content
management and and arbitrary content
types in this case the content would be
products for sale you know you you
cannot get away from having these
ridiculously exploding decoupling
structures in relational tables that is
why exists so get us away from
that nonsense anyway so no there was no
direct integration was being used
purely as my playground to take data
from a couple of different places a
description file and multiple different
Excel spreadsheets that contain Product
data mingle um and then do you know
offline queries whatever I wanted to on
answer your question please
ah no no heavens no should or the
database oh this thing ah I didn't um I
didn't magento has an API that I am sure
the developer who i outsource the work
to customize the back end in magento use
to take CSV data and insert them into
the this my sequel database I didn't
touch it at all and it was sort of they
were separated layer wise by a buying
uploader process written in PHP that
lived on the server that would suck in
the CSV data that I produced and would
insert products into the database vaio
magento aethiops yes I yes it sucks
right the one people yeah it's ready I
guess
they will right exactly I insist my
sphere yeah any other questions yeah so
why was not a good choice versus
something like elasticsearch solar
excellent ok so a couch couch couch um
couch does not have aggregation does it
yeah does now high rate doesn't have
features it to keep out the the the
essence of what I'm trying to
communicate is exactly that that a mono
is a general purpose solution that it
offers features it emphasized features
and tried to end this is actually a
nurse you should listen to elliott talk
there's videos available about that that
that design principle where we're trying
to balance speed with features and there
are a lot of projects out there that
have decided they're going to do one
thing to do well they're going to be a
pure in you know then 30 min cash
rabbitmq all these solutions that
involve creating really rapid
synchronize data structures that you can
insert pull out of and everything but
they don't offer any they don't offer
any you know features where you can say
well I want to work with the data I want
it to
want to interrogate it and certainly I
want to do queries I want to match
against it I want to filter when you
aggregate on a you know partition and
you know and have it be persistent to
elasticsearch I mean I think that's just
overkill for for trying to get for
trying to get you know Excel sheets to
be merged with some some pre tax
documents that describe products and
that's the same rationale that I would
use to say that ORM is overkill to do
stuff like that it's like I didn't even
want to write you know later I went back
and rewrote some of this code to be
object oriented so that I could play
with the behavior driven development
stuff that I was going on about but I
didn't even want to write objects so
like why if I'm just doing procedural
code how many had used RM there's Matt
and objects to two tables it's uh you
know there's too much overhead there's
too much configuration you know you
gotta questions about like oh you know
what happens how do we how do we set up
cascading deletes as far as key
relationships all this link no just you
know I just want to take data the way I
see it like collections of attributes
and hatches and arrays like our horses
name I'm sorry about that right right I
mentioned is just the way to think you
know we're thinking about data now ok
was that a good answer answer your
question any other questions
alright well I want to thank balcom for
hosting us